more specifically about the health and
clinical informatics major
um which um i
um direct that part of the program this
is more
my area of expertise in informatics than
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine
so the primary goal of the han major is
to educate future developers and
managers
of health and clinical information
systems
so individuals come in with a variety of
backgrounds
and are given a strong technical
grounding in biomedical informatics
health and medicine so understanding
the healthcare system you don't need to
be a healthcare practitioner but
understanding the how the healthcare
system works
data and computing sciences and
organizational management sciences
so that they may graduate and hopefully
assume positions that require a thorough
understanding
of both information technology and the
healthcare environment
so as i mentioned in the last half hour
there each of the majors has domains
and within these domains are either
required
or individual competencies where you
select
individual courses from lists or
electives
so there's the core domain of biomedical
informatics
there's a domain of health care if
you're already a health care
professional
there's a there's a course about the
practice of health care
that you don't need to take you you have
to substitute another course for that
we have another domain that we currently
call computer science but we're actually
in the process of changing the name of
that to data
and computing sciences again just
recognizing the importance of data
science
in health and clinical informatics
especially people who work in
health care settings organizational and
management issues are really key
and that's a part of our curriculum as
well in addition
um evaluation um
learning how to be able to evaluate
informatics projects either from an
operational standpoint or from a
research standpoint
and then depending on what program
you're in you do your
capstone if you're in the master's
non-thesis
thesis if you're in the masters with
thesis and
advanced courses and dissertation if
you're in the phd program
so informatics is not a spectator sport
you will spend a fair amount of time in
classes but
we really trying to make things as
hands-on as possible
um and you can do that in two ways one
is to get involved in research projects
of the faculty
many students are important components
of
important contributors to research
projects
and um but another type of hands-on
activity is being involved in
operational activities so working in
a hospital clinical informatics
department um state public health
department a number of our students have
done that
um working with our
clinical research informatics group at
ohsu supporting the informatics needs of
researchers
so there's a variety of possibilities
you can pursue this as a practicum in
the
master's program or an internship
in the master's non-thesis program
and and actually even phd students can
do an internship if they're
um interested and of course the work
that you do
when you do these hands-on projects may
lead to capstone
thesis or dissertation
um i mentioned in the last hour that
there's been a lot of work done in the
last few years better
trying to better characterize the work
of people who
work in informatics professionally
and one of the major changes in the
field has just
been this growth of this domain of data
governance and analytics but these are
the
domains of work that you need to have
competence in
so you obviously need foundational
knowledge
about informatics computing healthcare
and so forth
um and and there there's two of these
because the the
the one on the bottom was actually done
originally um
for the physicians in the clinical
informatics subspecialty
the one above it focuses on health
informatics more broadly
these were done as two separate analyses
and and almost ended up with the exact
same results you see the names of the
domains are a little different
um so um so what do people who work in
informatics do they they need that
foundational knowledge
they have to understand health and
health care
including decision making processes and
outcomes
they need to understand information
systems whether they're
in the healthcare enterprise or other
kinds of information systems
they need to understand data which i've
already said
and it's important for the
for those who work in informatics to
have leadership skills
professionalism skills being able to
guide organizations
as they transform with technology
so this um is a nice picture these
articles are available um
freely available online from the website
of the american medical informatics
association it gives you a real clear
picture
of if you end up working in informatics
what you would be doing
either from a research perspective or an
operational perspective but
focusing on these kinds of areas
so this word data science is
it has become a big thing and
we believe that data science is
part of informatics highly overlapping
with informatics maybe even
part of informatics um but there's a
nice
paper that a colleague philip payne
wrote and um this
cycle of informatics and data science so
basically if you look at the upper part
of the figure
there are things that go on in the world
biological things social things
technological things
and we observe what those
we observe those processes sometimes
called afferent processes where we go
from the world
to knowledge or representations of
knowledge
and that's a critical part of data
science that measuring
instrumenting observing what happens in
the world
and that by studying the world
we gain knowledge that we can use to
improve health and health care
informatics does more in that we take
that knowledge
we and we apply it back to the world
we apply it in the development of
electronic health records
in research information systems in
mobile devices um we look at the impact
that that knowledge and technology have
on those on
people in the world and and this is a
critical part of informatics that
for programs that just focus on data
science don't
always focus on these other important
things and there's other skills
so you see the core skills at the bottom
for data science
algorithms machine learning statistics
databases
the core skills for informatics um and
and
and actually the core skills for data
science are also skills for informatics
but
informatics in addition skills and
evaluation
in this notion of implementation science
how do we best
implement healthcare and healthcare
processes
organizational theory human computer
interaction so you can have all the
great data in the world
but if people can't use the systems to
get access to the knowledge that was
generated from that data
it's it's a missed opportunity and
workflow
any of you who work in healthcare
settings know that the workflow of
healthcare
is very complicated
so there are um plenty of high-paying
jobs
in health and clinical informatics um
these numbers are a few years old
but you see that people who work in for
different types of organizations
consulting companies software
companies academic government health
care systems
doing different kinds of jobs and then
you see some of the different jobs that
people do project management it
management
informatics proper um implementation
consultants and clinical
informatics clinical applications the
and the these are average salaries from
a
website unfortunately they don't publish
these numbers anymore
but um i thought it was good when they
did
but in any case um these numbers are
actually higher for certain groups
so clearly there's huge demand for
people with skills and data analytics
um their um physicians
um make more doing informatics than
than other parts of the field they're
oftentimes in leadership roles they draw
on their
medical training and then the high-end
leadership not only
cmios but chief information officers
cios
chief technology officers etc
make higher salaries
so um this is just a repeat of our
online and a repeat of
my
contact information
i'm i'm gonna stop sharing and go back
and um
i will be happy to answer any questions
you can either
it looks like there's nothing that's
been added since i started
um and um uh there's also some other
uh faculty and staff here um who can
potentially answer those questions
so you can either um type into the chat
box
or feel free if you want to unmute and
i'd be happy to
answer any questions or refer them to
the others who are here
well um if there are no
further questions uh we can um
adjourn and i guess um uh oh wait here
we go
um what are the specific benefits of the
program for students who are already
working in a full-time informatics role
that's a great question
there are lots of people who work in
informatics roles who have no formal
training in informatics
that um that they they play very
important roles and informatics um
you know is a field that that has not
been around a tremendously long time so
there are naturally people working in
the field who are not formally trained
um we have had a number of uh
over-the-air students who are already
working in informatics and it's enabled
them to
advance their skills um sometimes people
feel limited
because a lot of the um what's happening
in informatics they don't have
formal training in they'd like to be
able to spend more time
um learning more about these specific
things
um learning more about data science data
standards
um other areas that that we've covered
so that that would be the benefits for
those who are already
in informatics roles there's also
benefits um
in some organizations you earn a higher
salary if you have a master's degree and
um uh those sorts of things as well
but um you know clearly if you know
everything about informatics then
um it may not be that good of use of
your time but um
if if there are areas where you can grow
we try to
tailor the curriculum um in a way that
you can be sure
to get the skills in the areas where
where you're
less skilled so you can move forward
well um so um
i see lauren is here
they restart at 1 30 or whenever people
i guess come back from bcb is that
correct
you're unmuted but we can't hear you
okay so if you could just um type in
yeah okay
oh great um okay so um
um yeah so i'm i'm gonna mute myself
and then um we'll restart at 130
or um whenever um the bulk of the
bcb people attending the bcb students
get back and yes
take a 10 minute break and lauren will
will also fix her audio
so thank you all
you